german politics is generally seen as
honest and transparent
germany is the world's ninth cleanest
country according to transparency
international
here pale blue shows countries
transparency ranks as clean
and the darker the blue the more corrupt
on the ranking
but germany's parliament has recently
seen a series of scandals
prompting outrage several mps from
chancellor angela merkel's conservative
bloc have stepped down as a result
allegations include mps taking payments
from azerbaijan's government in exchange
for support
others profited from deals to make or
supply face masks in the pandemic
now many say germany needs tougher laws
to control its mps
what happened in the last weeks in
germany is
a huge threat for
in general the trust of citizens towards
their politicians
it's um something that will turn
so many people away um from politics
and that's a huge problem we cannot
let it happen and it's it's a very it's
a big danger i think for democracy
so what can and can't germany's
politicians do
german mps receive a pre-tax salary of
around 10 000 euros per month
they are allowed to earn money on the
side as long as their work as an mp
is their main focus
about a third of mps say they do have
other sources of income they must
declare how much they earn on top of
their government salary
once the extra is more than 1 000 euros
a month or 10 000 euros a year
but they don't have to declare the exact
amount and there's no
upper limit
mps also have to make a declaration if
they own more than 25 percent of a
company
but they don't have to reveal what their
companies do
which other firms they do business with
or how much all of that is worth
critics say that leaves too much room
for conflicts of interest
if there are rules in germany people
generally follow the rules
but if you don't have a rule of course
people
take the liberty not to necessarily for
follow any moral guidelines but take it
to their advantage
and at the moment there are
unfortunately a lot of loopholes
in the codes of conduct for members of
parliament as long as they are loopholes
there will be people trying to take
advantage of it
the government has recognized it needs
to change things
the key parties have drafted suggestions
to tighten the laws
critics say the plans are still too weak
and the overall situation has attracted
international attention
last year the council of europe's group
of states against corruption
called on the german government to set
up stricter rules around transparency
its report said parliament needed
stronger safeguards against conflicts of
interest
and also highlighted another area of
concern
lobbying lobbyists work the corridors of
power using various tactics to influence
political decisions
they can represent huge companies or
whole industries but also single-issue
campaigns and smaller interest groups
lobbyism in itself is not something bad
um in a representative democracy
interest groups should have direct
contact to the policy
for the politics if we don't know as a
public
how and who
influenced law when a law is passed
in the end we cannot check if all the
interests
were hurt germany has no official record
of who is working to influence which
decisions
or how much time and money they spend
doing it
so compared to many other western
nations
such as the uk such as france canada
ireland the netherlands
austria and austria is famously corrupt
germany doesn't
really have a lot of rules germany's
governing coalition recently agreed to
set up a lobby register
it will force lobbyists to say who they
work for
making a false or incomplete statement
could cost up to 50 000 euros in fines
but the register won't require them to
say who they meet or how much they spend
experts say the proposal is a step in
the right direction
but that it should go much further so in
the end what we would get with the
current
um lobby register would be
a names list of who is lobbying
but we lack actually the rest of the
information
if you want transparency and you don't
get it completely covered
then you won't have half of transparency
you won't have any at
all with chancellor merkel set to leave
politics after september's election
germany is entering a period of upheaval
democracy depends on voters trusting the
system
and soon they'll show politicians just
how deep that trust
[Music]
runs
you